cuando fue la última vez que pensaste
necesito un cambio radical en mi vida
sientes esa necesidad de descubrir cosas
en ti para poder cambiar pero no sabes
cómo empezar
cuando fue la última vez que sentiste
esa pasión auténtica por lo que haces o
no será que te sientes frustrado por qué
cambiaste aquello que amas por lo que te
conviene
las presiones sociales la familia y el
deber se fijan estereotipos que nos
llevan a aceptar cosas que en el fondo
no amamos y esto puede llegar a destruir
nuestra vida de hecho llega el punto en
el que somos tan infelices que queremos
culpar a otros de nuestra infelicidad y
tú eres el único culpable de tu
felicidad o de tu infelicidad
hoy quiero contarles la historia de un
gran amigo la historia de jesús esta
persona me hizo reflexionar muchísimo
sobre mi vida y sobre el camino que
estaba tomando
cuando iniciaba mi proceso para
convertirme en coach de mindfulness fui
a un retiro de cinco días de meditación
y ahí conoce a jesús un mexicano de 45
años que había montado una empresa
increíble en australia
esta persona ayuda a muchísima gente de
todo el mundo para ir a australia a
estudiar ya trabajar
jesús está casado y tiene dos hijos
hermosos todos los días sale por las
mañanas a correr a la playa y por las
tardes sale con su familia a ver el
atardecer su vida parecía perfecta
siempre estaba arreglado amigos y
siempre con una sonrisa en la boca hasta
parecía que no lo había costado nadie
llegará ahí así que por supuesto me dio
muchísima curiosidad y yo quería saber
cómo le había hecho para ser tan feliz
entonces le pregunté jesús qué hiciste
que hiciste para ser tan feliz
y jesús me contestó
no siempre ha sido así de hecho mi vida
había tomado un camino completamente
distinto a este hasta que me salvé de mí
jesús se transformó gracias a que se dio
el tiempo de hacer una pausa en su vida
y es que resulta que vivimos en una
máquina del tiempo nuestra mente se la
pasa viajando del pasado al futuro y del
futuro al pasado todos los días
constantemente hasta pareciera que la
vida si no se está escapando de las
manos
y les voy a dar un ejemplo muy sencillo
que seguro a todos ustedes les pasa
todos los días por la mañana cuando nos
estamos bañando automáticamente estamos
pensando en qué es lo que vamos a
desayunar
cuando estamos desayunando en vez de
disfrutar nuestros alimentos y saborear
los estamos pensando en qué voy a hacer
en el trabajo
y cuando llegamos al trabajo en vez de
disfrutar nuestro trabajo o enfocarnos
en las tareas de ese día estamos viendo
el reloj a d'anoia me quiero ir a mi
casa ya ya me quieres y entonces cuando
ya por fin llegamos a la casa en vez de
descansar de disfrutarlo con nuestra
familia con nuestros hijos estamos
agobiados pensando en el día siguiente
entonces cuando vivimos el presente
cuando vivimos el aquí y ahora
regresemos con la historia de jesús hace
8 años era una persona completamente
distinta al que yo conocí jesús
trabajaba más de 9 horas al día en la
empresa de seguros que él había heredado
su papá le iba muy bien claro voy a
tener un muy buen nivel de vida el
problema fue que incrementó las horas de
trabajo
imagínense llegó el punto en el que ni
siquiera tomaba días libres ni siquiera
los fines de semana
jesús diría en una burbuja trabajando
sin propósito y con hambre mucha hambre
de dinero y de poder y todo por cumplir
las expectativas de su padre
y de la sociedad jesús se había olvidado
por completo de sí mismo y del sueño que
algún día tuvo que era vivir en nuestro
país
hasta que la vida la vida misma lo hizo
parar ataques de pánico y de depresión
inundar su vida hasta tocar fondo
una noche sentada en su oficina le
ocurrió un accidente que le cambió la
vida por completo
sufrió un ataque de pánico tan fuerte
que se quiso solventar con una dosis de
ansiolíticos el problema es que la
medicina esta vez le jugó una mala
pasada
esto le pasó porque no descansaba y
tenía muchísimo estrés jesús perdió el
conocimiento se pegó en la cabeza contra
su escritorio y jesús desesperadamente
intentó llamar a su papá y no le
contestó
intento llamar a su mejor amigo al cual
había dejado plantado más de tres veces
por estar trabajando y que creen no le
contestó intento llamar a su novia
a la cual había desatendido millones de
veces para estar ocupado
y evidentemente tampoco le contesto
jesús estaba solo completamente solo
y había perdido mucha sangre pero había
perdido algo más importante las ganas de
vivir
afortunadamente el personal de aseo de
sus oficinas pasó por ahí y pudieron
rescatarlo cuando llegó al hospital
evidentemente le preguntaron qué le pasó
entonces platicó absolutamente toda la
historia y el doctor le dijo jesús me
parece que estás en una franca zona de
autodestrucción así que si me pides un
consejo solo te voy a decir una cosa
salva te de ti
esta historia
nos deja el siguiente aprendizaje
cambia el debo ser por él yo soy es
decir si tienes ganas de cantar canta si
tienes ganas de llorar llora y que no te
importe quién esté enfrente de ti si tu
sueño fue irte vivir al congo vete a
vivir a el congo
que de verdad no te cansa no estar aquí
ya bájate de esa máquina del tiempo
amigos la vida es hoy no la
desperdiciemos haciendo algo que no nos
apasiona así que a ti te digo aquí y
ahora salva te ti
[Música]
[Aplausos]